الان مباشره من كييف موفيز الى هناك عبد
القادر درماس عبد القادر اهلا ومرحبا بك
معنا عبد القادر دعنا نبدا باخر التطورات
الميدانيه
مرحبا رشيده بامكاننا القول ان معنويات
الاوكرانيين هذا الصباح في الحديد على
الاقل الاوكرانيين الذين تحدثت اليهم منذ
الساعات ساعات ساعات الليل الاولى بسبب
القصف الذي يستهدف مدينه كراماتورس
التابعه لمقاطعه
البلاد
تتضارب عفوا الروايه روايه موسكو مع كيف
السلطات الاوكرانيه تتهم القوات الروسيه
باستهداف مباني سكنيه واسقاط عدد من
القتلى والعشرات من الجرحى من الجهه
الاخرى السلطات فكره المواليه لموسكو تقول
ان الجيش الاوكراني هو من استهدف هذه
المدينه على كل في في شرق اوكرانيا تكثف
القوات الروسيه عمليتها العسكريه منذ
بدايه الحرب مؤخرا مجموعات فاجنر اكدت
سيطرتها على سوليدار وبعدها
براهو داتني هذه المنطقه المتاخمه لمدينه
بخموت على بعد كيلومترات فقط تريد فاجنر
عن طريق امام الجيش الروسي النظامي من اجل
اختراق المدينه وصولا الى كراماتورس لقطع
الامدادات العسكريه على الجيش وايضا من
اجل ربط المحور الشرقي بالجنوب الغربي من
جهتها لم تؤكد ولم تفند الى حد الان
السلطات او الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
سقوط مدينه باكمو التي اشتدت فيها القتال
منذ اشهر ايضا السلطات الاوكرانيه اكدت
انها قامت بقصف مجموعه من شبكات خطوط
السكك الحديديه في منطقه بخموت لقطع
الامدادات العسكريه عن الجيش الروسي
الامدادات القادمه من الجنوب هذا شرقا
بالحديث اذا على المحور الجنوبي اكدت بعض
المصادر المحليه ان ليله امس ايضا عرفت
تجدد القصف المدفعي الثقيل على مدينه
زابوريجيا وايضا على مدينه خرسون باسواريخ
بعيده المدى القادمه من شبه جزيره القرع
المتاخمه ومن السفن البحريه الموجوده في
البحر الاسود
طيب عبد القادر على الصعيد
الدبلوماسيلا ينتصل الى كياف عشيه انعقاد
هذه القمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه
بالفعل هي مجموعه من الاشارات اراد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يجدد دعمه الكبير ولا
مشروط لاوكرانيا في حربها ضد روسيا
غردت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه قولها انها
للمره الرابعه تصل الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه
مع مجموعه من الدبلوماسيين والمفوضين
الاوروبيين في اشاره الى تجديد دعم
الاتحاد الاوروبي
لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب التي تقارب على
على عامها الاول دون اي اشارات لتهدئه اكد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان انه قدم دعما يصل او
يتجاوز الخمسين مليار دولار دعما عسكريا
وماديا الى اوكرانيا منذ بدايه الغزوسي
على اوكرانيا شكرا لك عبد القادر على كل
هذه التفاصيل كنت معنا ايضا مباشره من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه